je pense qu'il ya deux points j'ai
retenu mois la pure imagination parce
qu'en fait effectivement on est sûr sur
une vision pluriannuelle et qui est une
vision qui est tout à fait intéressante
et du taux du temps de travail et puis
effectivement la monétisation qui est
positionné possible d'un certain nombre
de journées de rtt et j'aimerais avoir
l'avis de l'économiste sur les
propositions qui viennent d'être faites
par franck morel en ayant déjà un peu
ramasse et parce que sur ce domaine du
droit du travail en fait moi je vois
quand même quelque chose je pense qu on
a une occasion extraordinaire c'est vrai
que les français ont compris la
nécessité de refonder notre droit du
travail la nécessité de réécrire les
règles qui aujourd'hui empêchent une
grande partie d'entre nous de ne rentrer
sur le marché du travail
cette opportunité extraordinaire on est
en train de la gâcher pour une simple et
bonne raison
je pense qu on part un peu trop dans le
détail on est dans un endroit de
techniciens et donc on fonce droit dans
la technique et on en oublie l'essentiel
lesquels l essentiel aujourd'hui il
était d'abord d'expliquer pourquoi on
veut réformer du travail à quoi sert-il
quelle est la base se trouve du travail
il a été effectivement instruit
construit pour établir une relaxe pour
corriger une relation défavorable entre
l'employeur et le salarié
pourquoi aujourd'hui on veut réformer en
france pour une simple et bonne raison
c'est que les français ne travaillent
pas assez par rapport aux maintenir leur
niveau de vie et je pense que cette
règle de base avant même de construire
de décliner dans le code du travail
d'aller puiser dans les profondeurs de
du chapitre sur la sécurité ou là où la
santé du travailleur elle est nécessaire
d'être appelé aujourd'hui un français
travaillent 900 eur par an un français
adulte c'est le plus faible taux de
travail du monde quand on travaille
moins que ses voisins on est condamné à
être plus pauvres c'est la règle de base
on ne pourra pas maintenir un niveau de
vie élevé dans ce pays si on continue à
travailler moins que nos voisins les
autres je pense que c'est très important
d'exprimer cette vision d'exprimer tout
ce ce travail de pourquoi on veut
réformer le droit du travail avant de
foncer droit dans la technique ensuite
le second point de que je pense très
important à refonder c'est quand tout le
monde est parti dans cette voie de la
négociation collective
c'est quelque chose qui a été actée qui
a l'air d'être trans partisan
aujourd'hui bon tant mieux si c'est si
c'est la voie qui a été décidée allons-y
donc le schéma était très simple c'est à
dire aujourd'hui on part dans la
négociation collective donc on remet la
négociation entre les mains des salariés
des syndicats des salariés et des
employeurs au niveau de l'entreprise et
on va avoir un corpus
deux règles qu'on va fixer donc tout le
débat va porter sur le corpus de règles
qu'on va laisser à la négociation
collective est en fait tout l'enjeu sera
ici tout le tout le combat idéologique
va se porter ici et ce qu'on voit c'est
que là aussi on a quand on commence à
rentrer pleinement dans le détail sans
réfléchir à aller à ce qu'on veut à ce
qu'on cherche comme objectif final est
ce qu'on cherche c'est quoi c'est
d'avoir une règle très simple très très
plateau final d'avoir une une règle
s'applique à tous le tremplin je dirais
le le filet de sécurité qui s'appliquent
à tout le monde qu'ils soient le plus
simple possible
et aujourd'hui on arrive on commence
déjà à le complexifier et donc je pense
qu'il faut vraiment essayer de repartir
sur cette vision globale essayez de voir
les trois grands les grands axes qu'est
ce qu'on veut c'est une durée du travail
par semaine qu'ils soient fixés et ça on
la connaît effectivement elle et les
donneurs d'ordre publics européens
on a d'autres règles qui sont très très
très simple et le reste l'ensemble du
reste devrait être laissé à la
négociation collective en ayant en tête
un point qui est très important c'est
que les forces de production française
entreprises en france sont très
fragmenté et on peut avoir des régimes
très différents entre la grande
entreprise et la petite entreprise est
il à yahoo il ya un problème important
c'est que dans les grandes entreprises
il est très facile de lâcher du lest
d'acord les avantages aux salariés qui
ne peuvent pas avoir lieu dans les
petites entreprises et on peut avoir
ainsi une course à l'échalote qui se met
en place parce que dans les grandes
entreprises
il est très facile de négocier avec les
syndicats d'accord des avantages on l'a
vu sur les augmentations salariales
pendant que la dynamique des salaires a
été très agressive en france ces
dernières années dans les grandes
notamment à cause des grandes
entreprises parce que les plâtres on
lâche du lest à ses entrées alors
syndicats et ça oblige les pme ça oblige
l'ensemble du tissu industriel à se
mettre à niveau et ça le pousse à faire
des efforts qu'il n'est pas en mesure de
supporter donc il faut faire très
attention à cet effet d'entraînement et
a aussi à ne pas qu on fixe un an fixe
un minimum on n'a pas fixé un maximum
non plus que l'amp que l'ample que
l'entreprise pourrait offrir à ses
salariés mais il faut être très vigilant
pour faire en sorte que les grandes
entreprises en mettant des règles très
haute ne pousse pas les petites
entreprises à vouloir s'aligner ce
qu'elle ne pourrait pas faire
aujourd'hui et ce sera valable sur un
certain nombre de mesures par exemple on
le voit sur les jours de carence
aujourd'hui dans un sur un sujet très
spécifique mais sera peut-être demain le
cas sur un sujet de salaires un sujet de
temps de travail
et ça c'est très très dommageable parce
que le rapport de forces est très
défavorable en france aux petites
entreprises qui n'ont pas du tout les
moyens de lutter en terme d'attraction
des talents d'attraction des ressources
humaines par rapport à ces grandes
entreprises et donc aussi on a on a
effectivement un plancher à fixer on a
peut-être réfléchir aussi un plafond
dans la négociation